allez on va avancer Kev Adams Kev Adams
a évoqué avec émotion de sa maison
s régulières contre lui dans dans un
appartement voilà et oui oui on l'a fait
un petit récap euh et on en parle juste
après
c'est le nouveau Patrick Bruel Patrick
Bruel il casser la voix Kev Adams nous
casse les couilles
je sais pas trop quoi dire sur ça c'est
à dire que évidemment que j'ai adoré
faire ça ouais ça m'émeut parce que ça
m'attriste en fait le clash la haine
j'ai l'impression FEDER plus que la
bienveillance j'ai l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui c'est devenu presque
tendance ce côté on se met ensemble pour
détester aussi un artiste il y a quelque
chose de de qui fait du bien
est-ce que vous vous comprenez que des
célébrités se plaignent des critiques
qui peuvent recevoir en règle générale
donc prenez un panneau ah pardon
[Rires]
est-ce que les célébrités ont raison de
se plaindre des critiques elles
reçoivent non alors générale non parce
que la critique ça peut être ça mais lui
ça a été vraiment un déferlement de
haine et il faut juste rappeler que
c'est quelqu'un qui essaye de nous faire
rire de distraire on peut ne pas aimer
mais franchement il y avait des messages
haineux je ne comprenais pas donc je
pense que enfin voilà
on peut avoir des critiques par des
professionnels on peut avoir là c'était
de la haine pour quelqu'un qui essaye de
nous faire rire et de distraire et qui
arrive assez bien donc voilà j'ai pas
compris donc je comprends qu'ils soient
Gilles non franchement sauf quand ça
vire à la menace et que vous portez
plainte là c'est inacceptable mais
toutes les critiques elles sont le si je
puis dire la face obscure de tout ce que
vous de gloire d'argent de notoriété de
plaisir tout ne peut pas aller dans un
pays merveilleux
on est en méchant c'est bien plus facile
qu'en étant gentil c'est voilà c'est
compliqué de faire rire en étant des des
gentillesse mais c'est pas non plus moi
contrairement à ce que dit Daniel il a
pas subi quand même un arrêt de sa
carrière il ne continue à s'exprimer
excuse-moi non mais les messages on en
reçoit tous des messages de haine des
déferlements sur les réseaux mais là je
trouve que non les stars doivent
accepter la rançon de la célébrité voilà
et donc les critiques et donc la
critique
oui parce que je te comprends pas Gilles
parce que c'est pas parce que tu es
artiste que tu dois être une éponge à
merde excuse-moi
d'artiste et hyper sensible et donc il
était hypersensible et bah du coup tu
reçois encore plus violemment les
critiques donc c'est pas parce que tu es
artiste que tu dois tout accepter et qui
soit ému je le comprends c'est vrai
qu'il a pris il a pris beaucoup de de
d'insulte de critiques il en a été ém il
a pas arrêté sa carrière il s'est pas
retiré des réseaux pour autant mais il a
le droit de dire quand même il est
choqué par ça tu peux mais il faut
l'accepter c'est après
on peut le dire on peut en parler après
vous avez la différence il y a les
acteurs de cinéma sont très rarement
critiqués
c'est des gens qui sont plus rares ah
ben oui quand vous êtes quand vous êtes
tout le temps sur les réseaux à la télé
etc vous portez enfin c'est bon plus le
flan qu'on vous tape vous faites deux
interviews forcément il est très bien
c'est un acteur très bien payé
aujourd'hui dans Madame
sous prétex qui gagne beaucoup d'argent
on peut tout faire sur eux on peut les
affaires
il y a beaucoup d'argent mais quel
rapport célébrité est un choix personne
ne t'y oblige et quand tu es célèbre et
combien de te critiquer
c'est pas un choix c'est une conséquence
plein d'un acharnement et vraiment d'un
d'un harcèlement et c'est vrai que bon
il répond naturellement avec une
réussite parfaite sur sa carrière je
crois que c'est la il est très bon il
nous fait rire et je pense que c'est un
pied de nez à tous ceux qui le
critiquent j'en ai Alexandre qui lui
n'est pas dans le métier comme vous
people Alexandre mais non mais c'est il
y a pas que les gens célèbres qui qui
sont la cible de critique et c'est
valable dans la vie professionnelle les
gens du public qui font critiquer ici
parfois non ce qui est plus emmerdant et
pardon pardonnez-moi le mot c'est que on
est célèbre ça se voit les critiques et
donc du coup après il y a tout le voilà
il y a tout le personnel branding
derrière et et c'est vrai que ça prend
des proportions et des conséquences un
peu plus larges je pense
qu'effectivement en tant que ça reste
pas dans l'attaque et l'agression ça
fait partie du métier et c'est la rançon
de la gloire et il y a pas de nuit 100
jours et il y a pas de de gloire sans
critique d'ailleurs oui il faut aussi
des vannes
il y avait un problème
Nakamura
de mon dernier spectacle elle l'a très
mal pris c'est vrai que ça m'a touché ça
m'a fait de la peine parce que pour le
coup je taquine que les gens que j'adore
et donc évidemment j'adore ce qu'elle
fait je trouve que c'est son son géniaux
même si la personne
ne vous dira pas ça de moi
vous avez pas encore enterré elle a pas
encore enterrer l'âge de guerre non je
pense pas je pense pas je pense pas
il est assez honnête quand même
moi je fais défoncer par Laurent tous
les matins comme il avait raison dans
ses paroles on voit vraiment les paroles
de ce qu'elle raconte ça n'empêche pas
que c'est une bonne chanson et que ça
fait un tube on a le droit de dire que
on comprend rien ces paroles
comme je parle
je comprends très bien ce qu'elle chante
si il a le droit de la vanner elle a le
droit de la raison bien sûr il
fait un message
alors si ça dépasse pas les limites j'ai
pas les
bah oui sinon à ce moment-là on peut
plus rétorquer à rien c'est du débat on
rigolait c'est dans un sketch excuse-moi
si on peut plus rire des gens qui font
là malheureusement de nos jours tirer
sur une ambulance j'aime pas trop ça
on dirait il lui manque juste
écoutée dans le monde exactement le
classement des vins de Mickey
c'est vrai qu'elle est pas dans le
classement non mais Jean-Michel ça va
pas ce que vous dites vous dites que Kev
Adams lui il peut s'émouvoir des
critiques et elle elle ferait mieux de
rire de ces critique à lui
quoi
c'est fans et dès qu'on dit critiquer
c'est un génie absolue
[Applaudissements]